it's e3 it's like Christmas for gamers
on 2015 husband one hell of a year
I'm joined by Jordan from our lunch here
to talk a little bit about Mad Max Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas indeed and
what do you hear it's been but Mad Max
is coming out in a couple of months now
first of September 1st of September yeah
um so the movie obviously just kind of
steamrolled over all the box office but
this game it was originally gonna be a
tie-in is that right nope no never
intended to be a complete standalone
totally standalone so I mean I describe
it as it's obviously a huge open world
action-adventure yes it's set in the
post-apocalyptic universe that's made
famous by the film's so there are links
and we spent a lot of time making sure
that they are they resonate in the game
itself but it's it's a unique or
original storyline original characters
apart from Max and his antagonist
scrotus who's part of that world
and an original world built like from
scratch to rival the best open worlds
that are out there so feels like it's
it's it's totally it's totally it's that
it's not necessarily a direct adaptation
of any particular max storyline not at
all it's the toad in the feel of the
world yep so it's it if you are familiar
with Avalanche Studios games one of the
things that we think is important is to
promote the world itself to be one of
the main characters so we're trying to
we spent a lot of time getting
inspiration and sources from some of the
movies a lot of the lore of max stuff
that's written about them and we were
obviously want to faithfully represent
that in the world but it's a completely
new setting no story really cool
characters they're obviously reminiscent
of all of their quirky either unique
grotesque sometimes deformed is that one
way of doing it I mean because you're
not really under the
pressure of creating something that's
identical to what we know you can leave
your mark on it yeah well we had a lot
of freedom to make a game I mean we
can't make a game or maybe maybe you
could but it's not the Avalanche style
we really wanted to make something that
is you feel like Mad Max and then you
feel you want to explore a huge open
wasteland and you want to be the author
of your own story we don't want to force
a story upon you um obviously the the
overarching arc is always the same for
max it starts off in saying he gets
close to humanity the closer he gets the
more he brings disaster upon the people
he's close to and then he kind of
whiplashes back to teetering on the
brink of insanity again so that's his
arc but no so let's talk a little bit
about the wasteland so you've got this
huge open space how have you managed to
sort of fill that and keep it
interesting things that to engage the
player yep so from from the first moment
it will look like a desolate and sort of
open huge open expanse but we started
off when we envisage the world we
started off by building a real city so
we we have a anoi leur finery which is
gaston it has pipes leading to oil rigs
that are in the sea bottom the sea
actually has a volcano as well there's a
a industrial area that services the oil
refinery an airport close by a financial
district bridges and then we through the
apocalypse the world so a lot of its
covered up yeah the seabed is dried out
so initially it will look like you know
and it sort of desolate expanse but if
you take the time to invest in
exploration and you look for the clues
about how was this world built and how
did it function and you know you'll find
things like sewers and subway stations
and maybe even churches and diners and
all that sort of stuff so you can piece
together how the world worked and what
it would have looked like before the
apocalypse
nice that you've done in that way
because it's not in a way where it's
completely spelled out for you there's a
nice there's a hint of mystery to it
absolutely and we want to reward you for
exploring of course of course so how do
you keep the player kind of engaged and
so I mean it is a big open well this is
dying to be explored but how do you sort
of steer them back onto the main story
yep well we're not too aggressive about
steering people now there are a couple
of times where you you will you'll want
to hopefully to re re-engage with the
main characters yeah exactly
but we're totally open to players kind
of eking out their own trajectory
through the open world we have the world
is filled with both to the main
storyline related content and also tons
activities and encounters random
encounters you can work the world you
can build up alliances with some of the
like the people who are not affiliated
with scrotus grotus is your archenemy
and you can build up alliances with
those and you can spend time just
working and helping their stronghold
people get healthy they start making car
parts for you or building a water source
so that you can you have food and water
and so just there's a lot to do apart
from just you know seeing how max's
relationship with the main story
characters evolves let's talk about the
main story yep so max is on the quest to
build his magnum opus
exactly he's the car of Dreams the car
to end all cars how's he gonna go about
doing that in the wasteland he probably
would have been fine just taking his
interceptor and like getting out of
Dodge but he he had a tussle with
scrotus and his war boys at the start of
the game so he's been stripped of his
Interceptor stripped of his clothes left
for dead and and that's where you start
the game as Max and you basically after
your journey is to look for a body
locally you meet a companion and the
unfortunately named chumbucket
who is a wasteland blackfinger
a mechanical fanatic
vehicles and motors and and mechanic
life it's almost a religion to him yeah
so he helps you as the player or max
look for the basis of the vehicle that
you're going to drive and then you spend
time turning it into a vehicle where max
feels okay now finally I have something
that is powerful and sturdy enough that
I can survive getting out of this area
and and ultimately he wants some peace
of mind so the one the key thing that he
that max insists on having is a v8
engine rather than a v6 because he
thinks he needs to be able to outrun any
sort of terror that he encounters in the
wasteland so how does he go about
customizing his car obviously the the
wastes are going to be filled with car
parts either obtained legally or
illicitly yep how does he go about
adding them to the magnum opus well one
of the basic mechanics is that he goes
around and looks for scruff and he
enlists the help of some of these
stronghold leaders so they are not
willing just to give him charity so he
has to do things in return for them
helping him for further his car but
there are some project parts in the
wasteland in some of scrotus camps he
can infiltrate camps and he can he can
find more valuable pieces there also he
can take them so most Rhodes's convoys
either from a distance sniping or tackle
him head-on if he feels he's got a pair
of oh yeah with the shotgun
surely yeah exactly shotgun is always
there in the in the magnum opus and
there's a bunch of other weapons that
you can use the the trademark Avalanche
harpoon yes
which you'll see in the footage say that
was very well timed because this is some
of the vehicular combat yeah which you
guys have been shouting about it looks
great how how does it work oh here we go
it's kind of got like a bullet time yeah
so there are there are moments when we
want to help you aim with some of the
weapons the harpoon is a powerful
versatile weapon it can attach it can
rip armor off it can pull drivers out
through the windscreen it can turn one
of wheels like you see there and it can
also be used to
shoot thunder sticks which is like the
pole with an incendiary device on the
top almost like a rocket launcher that
this car also has something called side
burners which are two flame throwers
attached to either side of course so
that a bunch of different weaponry you
see I think you can see chumbucket
hiding in the back there he's hiding
there because as a board are trying to
attack max hopefully max will be able to
shake off the boarder jobrooker comes
back at and he's going to help you if
your car gets in trouble yeah climb onto
the front and start putting out fires
with his flamethrower or with his a fire
extinguisher so and all of that happens
in there in the heat of battle
I saw some sparks there as Max Max has
upgraded his car to include rims that
can shred enemy sha sees and then you
saw him using a shotgun and targeting a
fuel tank that was on the back of an
enemy vehicle to blow him up so how do
you know when your car is you know badly
damaged do you just take it to a garage
and chumbucket I'll fix it up just stop
the car and John will climb on the roof
climb air to the front of the car and
start putting out fires and tinkering
with his toolbox so an interesting thing
I read about is that there's a kind of
risk reward yeah when it comes to
upgrading and customizing your car
because you might add one thing but it
will negatively impact ya something else
they're extremely well informed I know
it's almost as if I did my research
yep so and when you go into the garage
initially early on in development we had
the garage was available as a physical
location inside each of these
strongholds so as soon as you got
entrance and made an uneasy alliance
with a stronghold leader and you could
set up a garage there and chumbucket
would add parts and so on but just to
enable gamers to experiment and try out
different tactics we've actually moved
that to the menu system now so right
from from anywhere inside gameplay you
can bring up the garage menu tinker with
your car try out different tactics and
you will see so for example let's say
you put a massive ramming grill on the
of your car yeah there are some
statistics that you will see that will
give you an indication on how it's going
to affect handling and acceleration and
traction and all that sort of stuff
so if your car is too heavy you simply
won't get any traction and you don't
have to find tires or an engine that
will match well with that ramming grille
that you've just installed yeah so it's
not about maxing everything out
it's about finding something that suits
your style of play you may want to build
a tank I can just run through everything
but that will have weaknesses when it
comes to rocky terrain and being nimble
and trying to you know you don't want to
be a beached whale so when it comes to
interval trading fortresses other
different ways you can go by doing that
can you go can't you stealth in or is it
you know shotgun first questions later
yeah there are we definitely want to
encourage the player to just scout out
locations a lot of these a lot of
scrotus camps have pretty heavy
perimeter defenses things like thunder
stick launchers on terrorists they have
snipers some of them have back entrances
one feature I really like is the fact
that if you pull the driver out of a car
that belongs to scrotus get in that car
it's much easier for you to gain
entrance there are civilians out in the
wasteland that you if you approach them
right you can get information about
maybe there's a side entrance or a
particular weakness that a camp or a
strong or a top dog in that camp might
have so lots of different ways to work
the wasteland
it's great I mean how big I mean it's
one of the awful question is how big is
the waistline if you can give us a
comparison to something like Skyrim
seems to be the standard okay I don't I
don't know how big Skyrim is big for
them I can say true to any Avalanche
game Alvin Studios game the world is
massive our engine supports an infinite
world essentially and we have you can
basically choose a direction and just
keep driving yeah and in our game it
gets more and more treacherous the
further outside the sort of the main
area of mission
content you get but it's it's big enough
that whatever you see you can go towards
and interact with and that's part of the
game but it's also a sweet spot of
ensuring that you have enough content
keep you engaged there is a touch of
mystery we want we want to so for
example another feature that we have in
the game is picture relics or relics
from the old world some of them are
photos some of them are notes from
people they've probably done just before
the apocalypse
they're the remnants of the apocalypse
and again if you explore you'll find
lots of you know treasure trolls and
hidden locations and interesting things
about how the world had the world's
demise came to pass so you're
anticipating a big long Wikipedia full
of all these secrets lands that would be
great some Mad Max game fun wants to put
that together that would be awesome
uh Sookie tell us when the game is out
and when we perform as we can play it on
a come yeah start a September September
1st to September 4th depending on the
region and I sided on ps4 Xbox one and
PC John thank you so much for joining me
cannot wait to play Mad Max my pleasure
try and hunt it down on the show floor
later today make sure you stay tuned to
hear the games what stage at e3 we've
got so much more great stuff for coming
right up